hey this is presh talwalkar
3 to the power of x
plus 4 to the power of y
is equal to 5 to the power of z
find all solutions for integers x y and
z
i thank mateo for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
if you experiment with the numbers you
might have come across the following two
solutions
3 squared plus 4 squared is equal to 5
squared
that's a famous right triangle triple
and 3 to the power of 0 plus 4 to the
power of 1 is equal to 5 to the power of
1.
if you found these two solutions
congratulations you have intuitively
found the only two solutions to this
equation for integers x y and z
but for a mathematician that's not good
enough
one needs to prove that these are the
only two
solutions i will present a solution
based on nick's mathematical puzzles
number 98
for this type of problem it's best to
read the solution and work through it
but for completeness in this video i
will present a video solution
however i will go very quickly
consider it a speed run proof
we will first analyze 3 to the power of
x
there are 3 cases for x x can either be
greater than zero equal to zero or less
than zero
we'll consider each case in turn
if x is greater than zero that implies z
is greater than zero which means that y
is greater than or equal to zero
we'll analyze the equation modulo three
three is equal to zero mod three
four is equal to one mod three and five
is equal to negative one mod three
we'll raise the first equation to the
power of x and simplify
we'll raise the second equation to the
power of y and then simplify and raise
the third equation to the power of z
we will then substitute into the first
equation
upon simplification
we can see that z has to be an even
number
that means z is equal to 2w for some
integer w
we can then substitute that into the
equation
then 4 is equal to 2 squared so we can
subtract 2 to the power of 2y from both
sides
the right hand side is then a difference
of squares so we can factor that
then since 3 is a prime we must have
that each of the factors is 3 raised to
some power
so we set one factor equal to 3 to the
power of a and we set the other factor
equal to 3 to the power of b
we have a plus b is equal to x and a is
greater than b
upon summing the two equations
we can then see that 3 to the power of a
plus 3 to the power b is equal to 2
times 5 to the power of w
if b were greater than 0 then 3 would
divide the left hand side of the
equation but not the right hand side of
the equation
this is a contradiction
thus we have b is equal to zero
we can substitute that in
we now have two equations and we're
going to focus on them
we'll consider each of these equations
modulo 3.
now
we will add both of these equations to
get the following equation
this implies that w plus 1 has to be an
even number which means w is an odd
number
let's now subtract these two equations
from here
y plus 1 must be an odd number which
means y is an even number
if y were an even number greater than 2
then 2 to the power of y would be
greater than 2 to the power of 3 which
is equal to 8. so let's analyze 5 to the
power of w plus 2 to the power of y
modulo 8.
on the one hand it's equal to 5 to the
power of w modulo 8.
since w is an odd number
we can analyze the powers of five
five to the power of w
must then be equal to five
but now we know that five to the power
of w plus 2 to the power of y
is also equal to 3 to the power of x
so let's analyze the powers of 3 modulo
8.
we can see
that 3 to the power of x is either equal
to 1 mod 8 or 3 mod 8.
so we have 5 to the power w plus 2 to
the power y is equal to 3 to the power
of x which is either equal to 1 or 3 mod
8. but now we have a contradiction
because we've shown it's equal to 5 and
we've shown it must be equal to one or
three mod eight
thus we cannot have that y is greater
than two
since y is even and it's greater than or
equal to zero
there are two cases that y is equal to
zero or two
let's work each case
suppose y is equal to 0.
substituting in we can then see that 3
to the power of x plus 1 is equal to 5
to the power of z
working modulo 4 we can then
simplify this implies that 3 to the
power of x is equal to 0 mod 4 which is
impossible
thus we have a contradiction so y cannot
be equal to 0.
so we're left with the case that y is
equal to two
let's substitute that into the second
equation
we can then solve that w is equal to one
z is then equal to two w which is equal
to two
so we have three to the power of x plus
four squared is equal to 5 squared which
thus means that x is equal to 2.
so this is one solution that x is equal
to y which is equal to z which is equal
to 2.
in fact that's the only solution where x
is greater than zero
there are two more cases to consider
so let's now work on the case that x is
equal to zero
we can substitute this into the equation
and simplify
we can see that x is equal to zero
implies that z is greater than zero
which implies that y is greater than or
equal to zero
let's now analyze the equation modulo
three
we can simplify this equation
we'll then consider the powers of 2
modulo 3.
we can see that z has to be an odd
number
from here we will analyze the equation
modulo 8.
we now need to consider the powers of
five modulo eight
since z is an odd number five to the
power of z is equal to five modulo eight
so we simplify this equation
now if y is greater than or equal to two
four to the power of y will be equal to
zero mod eight
so we thus have one is equal to five mod
eight but this is a contradiction so we
cannot have y is greater than or equal
to two
we must have y is equal to zero or y is
equal to one
so let's analyze each of these cases
suppose y is equal to zero
we can substitute in
we then get the equation that 2 is equal
to 5 to the power of z
but there are no integer solutions to
this equation so we cannot have y is
equal to 0.
we are left with the case that y is
equal to 1.
if we substitute y is equal to 1 we get
1 plus 4 is equal to 5 to the power of z
this has an obvious solution that z is
equal to 1.
so this gives the solution x is equal to
zero
and y and z are both equal to one
so we've solved this case we have one
more case to solve which is x is less
than zero let's work on this
if x is less than zero what would happen
if y were greater than or equal to zero
in that case z would have to be greater
than zero
in this equation let's subtract four to
the power of y from both sides by the
given assumptions 5 to the power of z
and 4 to the power of y are both
integers
so their difference will be an integer
but since x is less than 0 the left hand
side is not an integer
this is a contradiction in other words
there are no integer solutions for the
stated conditions
y cannot be greater than or equal to
zero we must have that y is less than
zero
if x and y are both less than zero
then the sum of three to the x plus four
to the y
will be less than or equal to one over
three plus one over four which is less
than one
this implies that z is less than zero
so x y and z are all less than zero
let's let a be negative x b be negative
y and c be negative z so that a b and c
are positive so our equation then
becomes the following
let's multiply both sides of the
equation by 3 to the power of a
multiplied by 4 to the power of b
multiplied by 5 to the power of c
we can then simplify this equation and
we get the following result
now 5 is a factor on the left hand side
but 5 is not a factor on the right hand
side
this is a contradiction
therefore there are no integer solutions
for these conditions
thus we've solved the problem
we can see that if x is less than 0
there are no integer solutions if x is
greater than 0 there's exactly one
solution that x is equal to y is equal
to z is equal to two and if x is equal
to zero there's exactly one solution
that x is equal to zero and y and z are
both equal to one
so there are exactly two solutions to
this equation in integers x y and z
wow
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]